voilà très très économe c'est pour ça
que je n'arrive pas à comprendre tu vois
on parlait de assez souvent de Benjamin
Castaldi qui a dépensé une fortune en
voiture et ça jamais jamais ça vous
comprenez pas par exemple je comprends
pas qu'on dépense autant d'argent quand
on en a quand on en gagne je pense on
sait que c'est très compliqué pour lui
en ce moment hein il faut avoir cette il
faut avoir le sens de l'économie des
dépenses savoir ce qu'on fait etc moi
j'ai toujours
éduqué je sais qu'il faut faire
attention avec son argent c'est une
histoire d'éducation vous croyez pas
pour dépenser autant et puis après se
retrouver à la rue avec
en devant de l'argent aux impôts ouais
je trouve qu'il y a un truc qui est qui
lui a échappé quoi je peux pas juger que
Benjamin c'est moi qui a amené son nom
sur le tapis mais il y a des gens qui
savent pas gérer moi ce que j'aime c'est
mon ami Jordan Deluxe et bonne école le
gars il a dit il enfonce vraiment dans
la merde il est dans une merde
Benjamin après texte il est cool après
méchamment je comprends très bien qu'il
dit ça voilà après il a pas tous les
tenants
refaire l'histoire
de la faillite de Castaldi non on essaie
dessus
tout va mieux tout va mieux maintenant
ça ça là je m'en sors ça y est mais
avant non mais c'est vrai que j'ai
clairement j'ai quand j'ai réussi je me
suis pas caché de
[Applaudissements]
très bien et on dépense beaucoup
d'argent
c'est beaucoup d'argent et et en fait
voilà j'ai dépensé l'argent que je
gagnais donc pour ça je n'ai de le soir
de personne donc si je devais le refaire
je le refais voilà
première connerie
pour le coup les impôts ça va être le
problème après il m'est arrivé d'autres
histoires j'ai mal investi mon pognon
mais effectivement si elle était plus
économe et plus voilà j'ai fait plus
attention à mon oseille effectivement
aujourd'hui on aurait certainement un
peu plus maintenant j'échange jamais les
10 ans que j'ai vécu de kiffe contre la
vie des autres aujourd'hui voilà on ne
vous juge pas voilà donc je vous le dis
et encore et encore une fois il a
évidemment raison je le redis ce que
j'ai gagné il s'était des sommes très
importantes par certains diront indécent
bien sûr
comment vous avez gagné depuis le début
de votre carrière moi j'ai fait les
calculs parce que comme je me suis comme
j'ai effectivement du devoir je prends
ma calculette j'ai dû devoir faire les
comptes sérieusement pour une fois dans
ma vie non j'ai pas un beau pays j'ai dû
accumuler une autour de 8 millions
d'euros mais non 8 millions
voilà une fois un peu partout
et après voilà et après vous avez après
vous avez les divorces vous divisez par
deux vous avez
divorce divisé par 6
donc vous disiez voilà et puis après
c'est vrai que j'ai eu la le le malpaule
ouais j'ai pas été peut-être assez
regardant j'avais investi massivement
dans l'immobilier qui est avéré pourri
effectivement quand vous investissez
2007 et que c'est vendu à la criée aux
enchères à la bougie comme ils disent
400000 balles il vous manque un peu
d'oseille à la sortie
mais maintenant rassurez-vous tout va
bien je sais que tu es toujours subjugué
par l'histoire de ma faute
indulgent avec texte parce que moi je
trouve qu'en fait c'est pas son rôle à
texte de défoncer Benjamin Castaldi
le son de bon gestionnaire à la limite
que ce soit un fils de Benjamin ou un
enfant très proche de quelqu'un de très
proche
de lui donner leur avis parce que ici
jusqu'à 25 ans oui mais sauf que il
connaît pas le passé le passif les
addictions les problèmes les aléas de la
vie quoi moi en fait il m'énerve un peu
dans cette histoire c'est l'honneur de
leçons en fait bah j'allais dire Mathieu
désolé
il a fait c'est pas ça c'est qu'en fait
il a fait des erreurs de parcours je
pense qu'il a appris de ses erreurs et
en fait ces personnes qui critiquent
c'est la plupart c'est tous des
hypocrites parce que demain ils sont
amenés à être propulsés comme il a été
Benjamin a touché des cachets comme il a
touché Benjamin la moitié aurait fait ce
serait fait plaisir à eux-mêmes aurait
fait plaisir à leurs proches donc à un
moment donné il a mal géré sa fortune
certes je pense qu'il a appris le but
c'est qu'il a réitère pas tout
simplement ça c'est sûr qu'il retarde
pas
sur TF1 30000 euros hors taxes tu
mettais la TVA ça fait ça fait ça fait
20 % plus voilà donc
les détails de TF1 c'était ça c'était
30000 euros une cote une cote c'était
entre 10 et 15000 €. voilà il était pas
voyant il n'était pas voyant il pouvait
pas savoir qu'il allait dévisser
qu'est-ce qu'on lui reproche aujourd'hui
moi j'ai toujours été j'ai toujours été
contre contre j'ai toujours dit que
Benjamin je peux pas comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui il est pas d'argent en
plus quand il me dit qu'il a brassé 8
millions je peux pas comprendre je peux
pas je peux pas le comprendre maintenant
maintenant si tu dis à des gens tu vas
toucher énormément d'argent comme
Benjamin est-ce que tu veux t'éclater
pendant 15 ans avec une vie de fou ou
est-ce que tu veux faire 40 ans à
l'usine les gens ils vont dire je veux
je veux la vie de Benjamin parce que tu
pouvais pas savoir que l'année
normalement
tu dois comprendre que quand tu fais ce
métier là
ça va s'arrêter
parce que j'ai moins travaillé que ce
que j'ai dévissé c'est pas du tout à
côté non non c'est parce que quand j'ai
voulu vendre les choses que je pensais
avoir acheté en mon âme et conscience et
de qualité et c'était de la merde donc
c'est très difficile
j'avais pas des [ __ ] qui m'avait
pris qui piqué mon oseille j'en ai rien
encore deux ou trois devant moi
excusez-moi
qui le connais extrêmement bien le
problème c'est que il recommencera à
chaque fois
c'est pas Benjamin Benjamin on le veut
on veut Benjamin Benjamin Benjamin
c'est relou et je peux dire j'aime
beaucoup cet été il est en hélicoptère
mais merde qu'est-ce que tu fous moi
maintenant c'est pas un hélicoptère
c'est quoi un hélicoptère un truc avec
une hélice c'est pas vraiment ça
moi j'aime beaucoup Benjamin mais je
soutiens texte entièrement parce que non
mais franchement Benjamin là vous êtes
non mais vous rigolez mais vous n'avez
pas retenu la leçon vous avez eu donc
[Applaudissements]
avec ça
voilà pourquoi
j'ai toujours préféré rouler en Ferrari
peut-être que vous avez vécu dans un
milieu je suis né le cul dans le beurre
[Applaudissements]
on me dit il aura une chronique contre
lui sur France Inter
chez moi il y avait des Ferrari il y
avait des belles bagnole déjà
50 GTB 4 waouh donc votre père était
très riche que je vous avais dit hein
qui a chanté qui a travaillé oui il est
bien sa vie au niveau de l'héritage
aujourd'hui
il est où cet argent
on dirait un gars voulez-vous faire le
mettre il est où cet on dirait un gars
qui est au placard on essaie de lui
trouver oui son argent ce n'est pas de
il est où l'argent parce qu'il y a plein
de gens qui sont ils sont en prison là
qui nous regardent je les embrasse fort
je vais aller voir la semaine prochaine
alors ça y est ça c'est des compter
c'est bon on va avoir l'autorisation de
la SPIP euh voilà donc je serai à
Villepinte la semaine prochaine avec mon
ami Momo à mineur et mon ami Jean Rachid
on viendra vous voir semaine prochaine
ou lundi ou mercredi
je serai là
je serai là alors donc c'est pas moi qui
est l'oseille
mais je vais pas vous répondre
tu n'as pas dit lapider l'argent du
grand noir quand même s'il te plaît je
crois que j'ai français mal savoir en
fait mes grands-parents à la différence
de lombelle MONDO et cetera n'ont jamais
été producteur de leur film donc
forcément là où eux
c'est vrai eux ils ont été fait le choix
d'être voilà d'être acteur interprète et
donc effectivement ça n'a pas de rapport
ni commune mesure avec des grands noms
du cinéma ils étaient très très très
bien voilà mais c'est pas chez
l'héritage
c'est pas moi c'est dans le jardin
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi il est où
les voitures est-ce qu'il en reste chez
moi
pour pleurer